a change has come over the
land in the last few years
farmers are turning to a new way of watching
it a new pattern new furrow lines new terrace
lines to hold the rain where it falls
to prevent it from forming in the Torah
it is a package that will fall the toll the soil
no matter what the / of wind or the wash of rain
fuels enriched with clover turned under
enriched with lime with phosphate enriched
for the hearts and minds and bones of
our children and our children's children
the farmers trotted over that
looks practical it is practical
six million farmers six millions fall beginning
to farm together to think together to act together
down in the Carolinas of an origin
in Bloomington Indiana made the high
Northwest the Texas place the face of the land
made over made strong again made strong forever
we are saving the soil but what about the
people not only beans the dispossessed but
all who struggle the rest are living from
the land this we know we can save them when
we learn to live with abundance when we learn
to make a fabulous machines disturbance of men
these miraculous machine the strength of
a man is not great he has not in his arms
and back the strength of a Greek machine
but manners of mind he can think he can
govern he can plan a new world awaits him
an abundance beyond huge dreams the great
fact is the land the land itself and
the people and the spirit of the people